[Música]
la explosión se produjo en la noche del
viernes en wellington un suburbio del
este de la capital de sierra leona según
las autoridades un remolque chocó con un
camión cisterna que transportaba
combustible una gran multitud se
apresuró con recipientes para recoger el
combustible que se estaba derramando
cuando todo explotó el presidente julio
humada vio que se encontraba en escocia
asistiendo a las conversaciones sobre el
clima de la cob 26 deploró la tragedia
estoy profundamente consternado por los
trágicos incendios y la horrenda pérdida
de vidas en la zona de wellington mi más
sentido pésame a las familias que han
perdido sus seres queridos y a las que
han quedado mutiladas como consecuencia
de ello mi gobierno hará todo lo posible
para apoyar a las familias afectadas las
imágenes publicadas en internet
mostraban víctimas gravemente quemadas
mientras el fuego arrasaba a las tiendas
las casas y los vehículos cercanos las
autoridades indicaron que las personas
heridas fueron evacuadas a varios
hospitales de la capital y que
trabajadores sociales estaban ayudando a
los damnificados
intentar colectar combustible es una
práctica habitual en algunos países
africanos
incidentes similares cobraron la vida de
unas 85 personas en tanzania en 2019 y
de otras 50 en república democrática del
congo en 2018